We're talking about
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert,
who finds herself in
an unexpectedly tight race
and what was supposed to be
a reliably GOP district.
I mean, very reliably GOP She,
of course, is a vocal Trump loya
She has national name recognitio
as beloved by Trump Republicans
as she is condemned
by liberals for election
denialism and antics like heckli
President Biden
during his State of the Union ad
or posing with guns for her fami
Christmas card days
after a deadly school shooting.
So what's happening with her?
Well, right now,
she is very narrowly trailing.
Adam Fresh,
who is a former Aspen
City councilman right now
by less than 100 votes,
he is ahead of her by that.
So let's zoom in here on Pueblo
south of Colorado
Springs,
to see why she and her campaign
may be very worried.
They should be worried
because this is a county
that trends Democratic.
And I spoke tonight with Gilbert
He is the clerk there
in charge of elections.
And he told me that
all of their outstanding votes t
were all Election Day votes.
They actually just reported out
2000 of those votes
that he told me
they were going to report out.
But the teams here, they are exh
They've been working 18 hour day
They need sleep.
So they're not going to be done
They're going home for the night
They're going to be back
tomorrow at Nine Mountain Time.
Which is of course, 11 a.m. East
And they're going to
finish the last 2000 approximate
But John and Jake,
that's going to be essential
to really seeing
what happens in this race
that now a lot of people are wat
that they didn't expect they wou
And it's interesting, I have to
one of the things
that makes me think
maybe over
is not necessarily in trouble
is that they're Election Day vot
because generally speaking,
the trend has been
Election Day votes tend to go Re
and early votes tend to go Democ
But am I wrong about that?
No.
Early votes tend to go Democrati
Election Day votes
tend to be more Republican votes
that that is that's certainly
what happened in 2020
and we see more of that this yea
It's you know
it's individual just got here
you saw me just popping around t
while you were
finishing
just looking for more votes
she was talking about Pueblo Cou
and you see
this is an estimate now
our team does our best
it's a midterm political environ
You're not sure
what turnout is going to be.
So we make our best
with our partners
to get an estimated reporting.
So as you made the point,
you know they're tired, they nee
but it's a Democratic area.
It's Joe Biden.
We carry this piece of it,
this county by two points.
But you see right now, Adam Fres
the Democratic candidate
is winning it by nine.
So he he's running
very well in this
traditionally Democratic area.
So that's one piece of the distr
that that's 11 piece of the dist
So that's some of it.
I mean, this is just
what we're going through
on a smaller scale.
Just we're going through
in Arizona and Nevada.
What's outstanding?
What part in this case, the dist
not the state are they in
and how many more are elsewhere,
Yeah.
So let's look at Pitkin County,
Okay,
this also trend strongly democra
I mean, very strongly democratic
The spread here is huge.
It's like four to one
Democrats, two Republicans here.
And I got in
I got a hold of the clerk there,
and she told me
that they had reported out
all of their votes as of 1:50 a.
this morning.
So the only thing standing there
they have some military ballots
that have until next week to arr
They have some cured ballots.
They have a very,
very small number of ballots
that actually went to other coun
that they are going to be counti
But this is important to look at
because this is an area
where I mean, he's
actually a former Aspen City cou
So he is just raking in the vote
here, right? Yeah. Although it's
It's a small county.
Small county.
Again, Biden
carried this small county by 52.
And so you see him carry it ther
So again, he's over 40,
the president
of the congressional district.
But to be honest point,
you're waiting for
those military ballots.
And so you wait a
you wait and see how it goes yea
And we say 95% estimated reporti
She says it's totally done.
But you have to keep in mind
that here in Colorado
they have eight days to cure vot
Right.
So someone made a mistake
on their ballot.
They have eight days
after the election to fix that.
So let's look now at Mesa County
This is on the other side of the
This is where Grand Junction is
They this trends in favor of Lau
Boebert here.
And they're waiting on approxima
5000 military
ballots, ballots
that the machines
initially had trouble
reading those cured ballots as w
So a picture here
altogether of just how razor clo
this race is
and will likely
remain is we're going to be wait
for a few more votes
And also as if
we didn't need to add more drama
if this race is
within half a percentage point
which it very well
could be as you're looking here,
it will trigger a recount
that's how Colorado goes.
So you can imagine how that is g
to play out.
Look at this,
because she's up by about 15 poi
in this.
But it's an hour plus 28. Right.
Very underperforming in
a Republican area.
You could make an argument.
We could make this case
in other districts, you know, th
some of the more Trumpy
Republican candidates have had t
in this environment.
She is as Trumpy as they come.
Bri was mentioning
some of the other controversies
in the past.
So is that what it is?
Would be great
to get on the ground reporting f
about without a doubt
that Donald Trump two years ago
carried Mesa County by 28 points
One of his acolytes, Lauren Boeb
as you know that's 15, 15.6.
Yeah she is underperforming Trum
consistently in all of these cou
that I looked at and keep in min
that her district overall
and it has changed look this has
but this was still a district
even with last year's redistrict
that was almost plus ten GOP dis
This is Colorado's
Western Slope
it's the southern part of the st
it should not be this close.
So you have voters here
really sending Lauren Boebert a
whether she squeaks this out,
which is increasingly
been up in the air here
or whether she loses.
And we were talking about this e
If you're in Colorado,
there were two other big races,
federal and statewide races, a g
who won 51.
It was 58% or something.
Governor Polis, 57.2%.
And then the incumbent
senator, Democratic Senator
Michael Bennet, 54.5%.
What does that tell you?
It says generally speaking,
the electorate who
turned out to vote in Colorado
was a little bit more to the lef
than to the right.
Now, that's not necessarily
the case in Boebert district,
but it seems like she's
had a much more competitive.
How did how did she win two year
What was her what was her voting
That the lines are not exactly
the same
is this is not it's not at
not exactly the same.
We can go back to the house now
and you can go back to the house
and you can look at the district
She got 51%.
She had a tough race.
Yes, tough race.
But, you know, it's
you can see the lines of the dis
are a little different.
And they redistricted it.
But to make it less Republican
that's our plus eight this time.
What was it last time
at the
slide that I
was able to say
yeah it's pretty close to like t
Some of the lines don't change t
but you see the district here
and you come you come back here.
But to your point
about the governor's race,
let me bring this up a little bi
Make it bigger
your point about the governor's
and you come back in now,
you know,
statewide candidates running big
But in the combination of
I wanted to just come back to
we talked about this before.
If you look statewide
at the competitive seats, right
where we go here, come back in,
come back out, there we go.
So you have the Colorado House r
six and two, two and competitive
So just bring up to just bring u
take the county off course.
The wall works
a little better to take the coun
I if you look at the competitive
here, right.
It's another state
we're not sure about this one ye
I'm not sure about this fifth
another state.
We're in competitive seats.
You have the Democrats doing bet
than the Republicans
would have anticipated.
What they thought was a Republic
And again, in this one here,
you see the six leading the vote
Republicans leading in two Democ
leading in two
of the competitive districts,
which includes this one right he
That is not that.
It's not the dynamic Republicans
we're thinking about two weeks
ago, four weeks ago, six months
But that is our dynamic today, t
after Election Day.
And also don't discount the fact
that Bennett and Polis
were pulling Adam fresh with the
when with voters that went to th
very strong candidate
with statewide help.
But to be honest point, often
those military ballots overseas
affect the margins.
In the end,
they matter here with a 64 vote